hello everyone and welcome to the ideal
talk for today which is Thursday January
the 30th and this is part of our ongoing
informatics discovery lab talk schedule
and today with us we have thanked Ron
it's my pleasure to introduce him to you
he's the CEO and co-founder of zoetis
incorporated which is a start-up
software company in the mobile health
universe and prior to zoetis that was
the chief technology officer of amdocs
limited which provides software and
services for the telecommunication
industry especially for especially
billing services for telecommunications
so if you ever received a really weird
bill from your cell phone carrier that
plan is responsible for that and prior
to our amdocs he was senior vice
president and general manager for b EA
systems and was involved in providing
service oriented architecture solutions
but somewhere along the line from this
pure technology background fan had
epiphany and ended up creating a health
care solution that he's going to talk to
us about today he has a number of
patents and innovations to his name he's
been honored for in it with industry
awards for his work but i think the
passion that drives him today is
developing this product at zoo ethics
and today he will be talking about so
ethics and specifically how the
application developed bioethics can help
clinicians by extending the
functionality of the electronic health
record and now we actually live stream
our talks so for those of you who are in
cyberspace I say welcome it is raining
here in Portland Oregon I'm going to
turn it over to Brett for one second
he's going to give those folks in
cyberspace the opportunity to ask
questions through Twitter and then we'll
turn it over to that for the lecture
today thank you so for those following
the live stream around the world you can
follow the conversation on twitter
through our handle at ohsu informatics
and submit questions
using the hashtag de maiz conf that's
DMIC e conf thank you
so hi everybody thank you for coming one
thing I would like to go through a few
disclaimer before I start first of all
I'm not a doctor and I'm a pure IT my
career up to the point I profound zeltiq
is oh aitee I'm doing a lot of
manufacturing finance you name it and
then don't know what happened after I
left em docks I decided to do something
totally different and I get in flighty
and we form a set of that team that have
a lot of a number of medical advisor who
give us and trying to train us to be
doctor but at the same time my talk
today would be very focused on how we
bring the IT advancement from the other
vertical and trying to see how an OP
health care in general so
I will I will jump into I'm not going to
go spend a lot of time in healthcare
challenge going to be browsed through
the set of problem that we're going to
solve with our King care product suite
and then we do a live demo and then I'm
going to spend some time on the platform
the collaborative platform that we have
we're trying to reserve at least 25
minutes per question okay so we take
this thing from Gemma and basically it's
about what a typical challenge in health
care would be i'm not going to read
through it but basically it's about
collaboration about communication about
medical Hannah about quality of care and
above all if it closer to the IT world
it's a lot of people talking about the
EMR insult ability okay and we see a lot
of change i'm not going to go through
all this thing that you face at the
oregon health and science but those
change is coming from this set of four
problems who data so EMR we put moving
the paper to pay plus putting the data
into a negligent form but that
electronic form unfortunately sometimes
is reflecting what healthcare provider
really see in a paper environment so
it's causing some disruption bottom line
is this I take the first code and from
somebody in this room right Vishnu you
know that first code this is 1300 data
point for ICU per day and care provider
have to go and look for that for the
database oriented the EMR system and
then by the way this is not just one
type of EMR it's a lot of different
involving the same thing the
circumcenter problem is the
communication failure so collaboration
and our process is manual I'm not saying
that we we don't have a process right
now but it's manual it the goal is to
see how IT can turn that environment
into somebody to support care provider
not the way around
alert fatigue actually I was visiting
the ICU it was confirmed number one
problem at the ICU say well what what
would make your life easier I load party
I get a load all the time I ignored
alert I sometime I load which is correct
I gotta tell them off and Aaron is my
witness that is my witness to third one
is earmark complexity and and and the
area of EMR complexity is also i don't
know about Oregon but in California
physician doesn't work for the hospital
and physician and carob dr usually they
have to deal with mental hospital what
if one Hospital use a pic the second one
is certain the third one happened to use
outfit how that doctor you can go engage
and learn oh this in the key things is
you make IT support the user not the
other way around and that's is for me
that the next problem that it's kind of
increasing it's coming from the email
into ability but there's a lot of
relation of your marginal ability that's
saying you know what if your doctor to
hospital merge what's going to happen
how you integrate that system so that's
more like an IT talk but from the care
provider you you want the oldest set up
for problem is very thick you want care
provider to the patient care not ID okay
so the solution is number one you have
to turn that data into patient
information you have to get that
information due to care provider at the
right time you don't blast them you
don't broadcast to them you don't tell
them all the time and say now the
measurement is 20 of 38 degrees Celsius
and then the doctor and the care
provider have to look at that that's a
waste of time but only tell them when
you really need it
you need to be able to leverage the
technology like cloud like mobile right
how I'm going to go that the one thing
about industry is blackberry you know if
you look at blackberry and I'm take this
example is blackberry changing our world
and say make any of us work harder
without even say anything you are
everywhere and your email wish to you
and you get eager to go to answer that
guess what you're working right but then
how but they do that voluntary they do
not and as a push system they push and
give that information to you and then
you answer if it's right but you don't
feel like this is like this is how you
scale up the care provided penguin and
time because you only get that
information and you'll be able responded
when you need you not not be able to if
that message is intent for Jeff it
should go to jail don't bother me okay
if it go to me I answer but then if I
happen to both jacking may have them
just look at both email at same time
fifty percent of what the penguin mean
look at that okay mobility you want to
be able to say which out to care
provider anytime anywhere ok and then
that is basically saying that if you if
you have a case and there is an alert
and the alert will reach you don't have
to go and chase and call the doctor and
things we have these mobile device they
are smart device they got capable to
handling a lot of data right how are you
going to get that how do you get that
information to be able to to get care
provider much more productive in a
mobile world and last but not least is
because I coming from the IT and a lot
of things it's it's kind of like
influence my my way of thinking a little
bit is my job at VA was I I come up with
I'm working in the early days with the
service-oriented architecture and I'm
seeing is you know in the world of
finance telco and things that you know
that mainframe computers you exist some
bank they don't take it away
they bring more value to that piece of
data how do you do that you you're
creating a bus and you expose this data
I'm from this bus and then you'll be
able to create new application on the
new technology a lot faster oracle
fusion have the same problem they when
they bought PeopleSoft about Zeebo guess
what Oracle have a set of CRM
application adding you to go to the
customer and say hey since i bought
Zeebo you have two chocolate this thing
and put that application in you know for
YouTube you have new feature from us
they cannot kick you out right so it'll
cost in the disruption to the business
and how you avoid that by creating a
layer on top of it and then enhance
their application on that top leg is so
that you seal up the legacy behind okay
so that's the way that I see it helped
them need to do it you're not going to
go and tell a hospital with epic ins and
the sooner guys say go and change that
thing and give sooner and then therefore
I will bring you more feature and things
that are nobody going to go and do that
bit of instruction every time you change
the EMR I take two or three years okay
so in turn architecture before I go into
the demo I basically walk through very
quickly of this the whole idea is at the
back here as EMR point-of-care
collectors information the data stay
there okay since the CMR and I used to
using an example say a pig speak English
sooner speak Chinese and how all these
things at store the patient clinical
data it is basically universal this set
of gateway in the back of these things
is basically translate that information
into humans occasion with your data
temperature heart rate are the same so
that gateway is basically do a
translator ematic add a mapping okay it
bring the data information to the
platform the server who sit in the crowd
and that server has two piece beside
normally normalizing the data it adding
also the message infrastructure that
basically other
able to say you can set a rule saying if
twenty percent of normal from
temperature don't go to the doctor
notify the news okay and then be able to
follow and make sure that nothing gets
fall in the trap then we put the fun
application on the mobile device okay
and not mobile devices right now we
started by having that thing on iOS
apple and then that's what it happened
and then we're going to talk about the
platform in the next few minutes so I'm
going to go fire up the the demo and
basically what I'm going to show you
today and walk through the first one is
the dashboard an electronic nose blue
sheet replacement on the mobile okay
then I'm going to go and connect you via
this mobile router that I have to my
cloud server who sit in san jose and
it's connecting to ninja four different
EMR system i'm going to show you how to
switch between of this thing and
presenting this information to the front
i'm going to walk through what the smart
alert lee and i'm going to go and show
the collaboration piece the last piece
i'm going to show is the ability to
saying that i can also fed rate the data
from inpatient and outpatient on the
same dashboard and be about you saying
that you aren't hospital you have the
ICU and you want to connect it and see
what happened what the family doctor
would say you'll be able to retrieve the
information and see for example kind of
chronic disease or history of that
patient without even poured things like
that ok
so I hope that technology will work
that's what
that
so the first thing I'm going to walk
through is what the dashboard demo the
dashboard look like and in this is Karen
collision so this is what we are
designing this placing on the North Pole
sheet and the ICU okay so you select the
patients and you see right away the
trends of the vital sign right now it's
happening for data but if you have more
than 24 data you can swipe it and it
move with you okay it's time collect
base and and look at the trends you can
zoom it or I have to say this I give
credit where it belongs this input is
from Jeff and Vishnu that use of you
that we have to put the hand on you move
the things now you have this one you can
turn on and you can move the data and
you can see the detail behind a graph
new trends okay now as a doctor or care
provider you sometime it as you you look
at me saying I want to see what the
vital sign along with mo dynamic data
that's how you do it or in case of I'm
an old doctor and I want to see in the
Landgraf I can have that too okay so is
it only hemodynamics it's medicine is I
oh and by the way every time like I i
move the graph it all go together it's
time synchronized across it is basically
designed information the trends and have
the eyes and the doctor basically say I
want to zoom in I want to see why is
that temperature going high and I want
to see what the impact output it
you can also retrieve all the lab
informations on that thing and then it's
recorded by the time where the sample is
is presented at a time where the sample
is collected okay ventilatory and neural
information so basically at the glens
you have the hour a time data on the
last 24 hours or you want to go retrieve
it back to five days fine go ahead do it
and you can you can swipe back and forth
okay now you can see that what happened
to that little funny teardrop when a
doctor enter notes are documentation it
basically denote as a teardrop and that
crap and it's showing that you can go
and see this dr. Tom Kennedy is writing
something about this patient also at the
touch you can see the patients having
when is admitted and what can a problem
and you see the allergy and also any
person to do that is thing so basically
we taking the whole 24 hours data or
whatever data we can retrieving a time
and that visit and present that in a
dashboard face because this thing on the
on the tablet we also be able to we is
this mobile so we will treat it is go to
the cloud and go to the back and EMR and
when you end a session guess what both
the cloud and the mobile devices doesn't
retain any data this is real time when
you access information and when I end
the session that okay now I also be able
to retrieve all the notes and I can
change the date and you can see the diet
on the on the side or I can also read
all the food medicine or full up and
then I'm going to show this is the
history is when we connecting to the
embryo to earmark or any other satellite
EMR around so you have to hospital that
dealing with that that patient and you
have the agreement to retrieve that and
be able to retrieve that information you
can do that also
ok now the bottom you can see a lot of
like button there watchlist the concept
of watch list is this if you have you
can set and i'm going to show you live
is you can set say twenty percent of
deviation from the norms go and inform
the nurse and by the way don't go to
owners go to the nurse who is active on
that shift for that patient if terry is
a news that he's on the previous shift
don't bother him please go home sleeping
but it had to go to that because she's
an active at that shape for that patient
and she happy to take care of it and and
if she doesn't acknowledge and do
something about it and when you hit the
acknowledge it will bring the note and
say what that can note down see how
what'd she do to address the problem and
if she doesn't do it three times we
notify with push notifications you two
to the device that associate with that
if we it fell free time that she doesn't
response they go to jab your resident
and you can set up pick up you can set
up those think my point is you can set
up all this thing at the point of care
by the faculty remember it's not like
something that you have to call the IT
and say hey can I do this for this
station at this one it is under control
of the care provided that okay the
circle notion is medical documentation
or medical orders so medical order is
basically associated hind that is a
workflow a a lab tests will be done
mutiple static each of the staff have
different people who doing that but
we're not we don't we're not going to
tell you how you gonna do that step but
we can inform you and and remind you
that hey he's the lab technician I
collected a sample already and I send it
so he going to get a notification and
say it's your turn now and when he said
done and go back to the care provider to
ekdum in the lab result so all these
things is designed to have nothing fall
through the crack on the medical order
itself and and once you look at the
medical order you
can see the miracle itself or if you
have a certain to do not lubrication
that's how we inform you that you have
to do this because it's on your
worthless on the fastest ok ok so I'm
going to go and
connect life I have to make sure that I
remember what they the data is
it's my cheat sheet 7 try it
honey
ok
so what I'm going to do is I'm
connecting and at the end if you hang
around I can show you that I shack
actually not cheating the data is coming
from the the EMR in the back San Jose
and I can connect you that also so
so I'm going to go and switch to to EMR
one is the this is open vista this is
coming from this stuff on the government
on the veteran administration and you
can see that I'm this is what it was
retrieving life right now that go to San
Jose and in the back of my cloud there
is a simulated just like you have you're
going to have the simulating epic I have
assimilated open be stopped it is
actually the open this idea myself okay
obviously so it retrieved information
and it will present the information and
you can see that I just tap on the
patient clinical data and what's going
on you just me work this morning
it's still retrieving the data so they
this is where we really retrieving from
the open Vista running system in a bad
why is it not sorry just a second
when you log in
the notion is is that when you log into
the system you login it pushes all that
data out to the ipad automatically so
it's not doing these constant fetches of
data so you have the the overhead of
loading that data out only when you
first log in
yeah you have to do that is predicted
that it have to have a network
connection and I find out one thing the
truth is when it is connecting with ipad
with a telco devices and varies on ATT
it worked a hell lot better ok this is
I'm just switching 20 script and I talk
to you about the ability to retrieve
this information from the inventory so
by switching this you notice something
in the back end is I'm going to the old
script or simulate in my cloud and then
now I'm switching to connecting to a
sandbox that actually is in O script
test lab right now ok and then nothing
work for me today
just a second
is connecting my little secure think so
you know what
look at how that i'm going to show you
this one because this one has tmobile ok
no it isn't just like it so safe so it's
a second for me
sorry about that but the defense is it
be able to present the information from
both and then I'm trying to get that
thing from my independent from the
browser here no something wrong with the
it could be that the the sandbox in Oh
script is now but basically what it is
is you'll be able to tap into that and
if you go to the clinic data EMR it
presented back all the matching name of
that patient on that database and then
the doctor will select and say I want to
see this patient and then a presenting
all the medical history chronic disease
the allergy what kind of medicine is the
two active at that time what is the last
music look like so that and in case of
the hospital they can see it and then be
able to also not missing any information
behind okay
it always
so I i want to also share the last piece
of informations on this piece is
this is one of the latest piece of data
that we do since this morning is we just
finished the porting of the connection
to the sooner and we are going to be
retrieving turner also so that
information that we can switch to the
sooner earmark and be able to present
the sooner information back so I'm going
to go and try to do that it's a lot
easier because it's just this morning
so I just which I'm sorry I didn't play
this thing on the screen properly but
it's basically I just switched to a
sooner EMR in the back and this is a
simulated CMR also back in San Jose so
you notice something at the same form
factor presenting the information the
same way that's number one number two
let me show you one thing when we do the
porting of turnip Weeden's change a
single line of code on this or the
server because the model big tape and
deriving everything on there so that we
can connect flood in additional
components okay
so basically the vision of zeltiq is a
little bit more than than just that few
application that we have we look at the
things that we look at healthcare
general and saying okay so is it that's
for application will be the answer to
every problem in healthcare the answer
is not are we going to be the only one
we're going to go to buy all the
solution healthcare next answer is no so
the way that we look at it and saying is
if I laid out flat oh d and this it's
not all everybody dealing with health
care in general because you have the
hospital you have the indolence you have
the clinic's you have a specialist home
care social network your family won't
know what's going on with you and then
medical devices all right so what
happened to all these things well it is
it missing the point that every time
that you do something you have to do a
point-to-point connection what you want
to do is create a bus that allow the
miscreant efficient flow to cross and I
just show you some of the elements that
we do with the EMR and be able to create
that connection across the ball okay and
how do we do that is if i look at the
platform a little bit deeper the first
thing we do is as I saying disparate
data for and by the way i use it the
term data source because it's not only
EMR microsoft health net it's going to
be a personalized health information you
want to be able to retreat that too to
be able to mix it right and then you
plug in a set of gateway and you
presented to as we move is the data
model now the universe that data model
is not good enough either it is need to
be presented up here as a push
notification I want to be notified I
want to push I want to chill healthcare
interactive mode okay that push
notification has to be there also
and then last piece is since this is a
platform we want to write a set
application to prove how the application
work but we know that we're not going to
write all of them so what we do we open
this interface so that third party can
come in and write that application now
the nice thing about it is they don't
have to worry about how connecting two
different data source I'll take care of
that it's called the duty would write a
set of library that we built it okay you
don't have to worry about going and get
a rule engine and things that it's all
configurable table you can use that and
change that set up so that you can use
it for diabetes disease control that you
have to have a different alert going to
do the ipad and iphone different okay
and then because you do this you can
work against any data source and your
application whether you have put the
type or innovative idea and things like
that you don't have to worry about say I
have to worry about dealing with epic
sooner and everything the information
get to you the same way and then go to
your back to the EMR the same way okay
how do we really do it
it's going to be a lot of different i'm
going to go very quickly to the stuff
that we have to do open this stuff mum
data based in the back how do we do it
we tap into the RPC between the terminal
and the backend database and we're App
Engine Java and we expose the
information as a doubt data extraction
to our gateway Oh script professional
EMR or the traditional classic oh el
squid have a different interface they
weren't on is but they have a unity
interface that we extract different than
the old scripts and rice ok soon you'll
have me remember object back-end
database is horrible you can know that
this is different database source and
then it goes through the web services
here they call think differently but we
map it and we'll make sure that is
everything good on word epic epic has a
lot of flexibility in configuration they
allow you to go there and in between
here there is a component name Chronicle
that is mums database retrieval we go in
there we wrote that function to retrieve
the exact data we want we wrapped around
with the interim interconnect and we
exposed by assault this whole the reason
is different color because we have to go
in here and creating a customized web
service set for it and when we have this
thing is exposed to this patient clarity
with the same format of data and then
there you go we expose it as the SDK
along for our care provider now the
whole thing about it is this SDK we're
going to open for third-party we're not
going to go and say this is so thick go
write it okay and then the second piece
we can open the SDK in the back to
here's why this is only five EMR it can
be a museum of things out there go and
take this Eddie's SDK and the data model
and plugged it in because that's how I
want to see the healthcare change
because we're not going to be writing
all this application neither we're going
to be writing all this gateway we want
to open that thing so that both end of
the highways connector
just one thing that I just eluded is the
dynamic medical messaging system is we
embed in there its ability to evaluating
the medical conditions and target alert
two different care provided by roll by
ship okay and then if there's a shift
change it basically follow and change to
the next notification to the new doctor
or the new member of that ship and that
is a certain piece of it is a message
infrastructure so to sum up what we want
to do is turn in the passive clinical
data into an active environment focus on
medical information and then make sure
that the med mechanical invention get
into the care provider to the right care
provider at the right time for the
treatment we want to be able to open our
platform for third party so that a lot
of people can come in and innovate
without the cost of dealing with the
infrastructure of IT Help DMR in
fashioning back end we're going to take
that away and we're going to embed it
and say that we even looking at
embedding future data application server
that allow you to set a pattern of
trance under green patient condition
that you can racing and application
basing on that so we take away all these
ugly things in the back and build it
engine ready so that you can build a car
lot faster and the way that you want to
do it and that's how our vision of the
ticket be able to say i want to bring
healthcare to i.t i.t to healthcare
basing on that for that I'm open for
question and right on time
and sorry the I'm more than happy to go
to WebEx with you guys later on to show
the actual demo okay yes I'm curious is
your platform api currently open or do
you have a timeline for doing that we
are currently open okay you want to to
work and jump onto that tomorrow I give
you the API and actually I'm nice enough
to give you the cloud service in san
jose for you to use that you don't have
to buy your own silver and install
yourself I guess add on to that is the
cloud server currently connected to real
patient data or just the sandbox patient
data right now we have only two sandbox
actually we have four sandbox one is the
actual open open Vista which is an
open-source thing that we download from
the distant world or share I can be the
next one we have Oh script is nice we
are a partner of Oh split so they give
us they actually give us the simple the
real EMR for the sunrise that we have in
our server on our partner and then they
give us to sandbox one is for the
professional and enterprise which is a
traditional Oscar Lima we are working on
getting with sooner
and we are counting on working with
oregon health and science you can see on
the good side yeah send your question
yeah so it's all test data yes so you
see that you download the data for the
patient into the into the application
for you know browsing and viewing what
happens if new data occurs on that
patient how did you know like a new lab
test is posted or something how does it
how does your architecture handle that
you can enter the data by our dashboard
depend on the EMR that supported by
function okay via that interface so let
me answer you very specifically our
script illios doesn't have a bike
function for us right now the next thing
is they do okay we can do that we opened
it up we can do that with enterprise the
professional server for hosted we can do
that this server so the data you can
enter the lab result or even vital sign
informations to to this there's two ways
to do it we
yeah yeah you double tap on the vital
sign information area it brings you to
let me let me get the things up and then
I'll show you
that
I'd up atop it
I can decide I can enter this data and
it go directly writing back to the ER
okay I can change.just I am saying the
threshold level of notification right
there for that patient and by the way we
have the neurons integration to when we
turn on the nuance you can say that
temperature 60 that that a technic man
it go directly to D the back and forth
over and we happen to write it again so
what about the other direction so you
know the aim or somebody posts a new lab
result in the EMR after you've already
loaded the patient and they're looking
at the data how do you you know how do
you update the user looking at that data
there for that patient at that time yeah
so we refresh we have a polling
mechanism in the back to detect new
information and the pudding is not for
you to display data is for evaluation of
the watch list the watch list okay but
because because the moment that you
locked in the time did you lock in we
actually go real life you would pull
that data at at that time okay there's
no refresh at a time on the ground
because at that time we you get the
information at the most up to date at
that moment okay the polling mechanism
in case that you we don't have the right
function to that emi is for the people
to enter the data into the EMR like a
vital sign something like that for us do
they say here this new data evaluate
lazing on a watch list
answer your question
yes discussion we had in the ICU
somebody might be looking at data
writing a note for an hour and if
they're looking at that you know a lot
can happen in ICU in an hour if they're
looking at that it hasn't updated then
there might be new data that they're not
we we can set the the polling as and the
nice thing about this is as much as data
that you say a 1300 at a point per day
for the patients or something like that
it's not deadly as the 18g system for
revenue billing that have 30 million
songs action today so the capability of
polling and other thing is it be able to
address that almost I'm not saying in
real time because we're trying to me
means differently real-time to me means
milliseconds I'm talking about near time
so within the five minute time frame etc
okay and we can talk about more
no no question I
yes um does your platform offer any way
for many for allowing clinicians to
manage the complexity of data across
different systems aside from just
showing them or allowing the taxes
records for different systems a time
because you know like you're giving them
like data not just from their location
but from a bunch of other hospitals
simultaneously yes I'm wondering how
your tour ups that manage that okay so
I'm not going to I'm going to get the
answer you straight forward right now
the right copy that we have is only with
vital signs hemodynamics and notes and
documentation ok the next phase we are
doing is the right ability or medical
order however I put a caveat we're going
to start with old medical error order
except for drugs because drugs and I can
tell you is the drugs the EMI have it
now they they check that drug against
allergy and everything big time and I am
NOT in the position to G I first of all
we're not here to replicate everything
that EMR is doing we are looking for
compliments that ok so i have an final
way to put the medical order in drugs
and take check the advantage of that
because all the EMR behave differently
and that department and i have not
worked on that out the idea but the goal
is to be able to write it back as much
as possible and addressing the most
frequent activity that can provide a
half that's why we pick the vital and
her mother is beside that is easier it
every day every hour in the ICU as an
example ok
and probably the question you asked and
say why is just iOS Apple devices not
because I like Apple devices it is we
start that because of the control
environment of Apple in terms of
distribution and everything and it's not
open source so that's number one number
two forgot to say you can go to appstore
and download this one demo however in
order to access the thing you have to
register the device to the be silver if
somehow say you lost the device we go to
the dis over and we will remove the
device even you have the password of the
clinicians you can't access it and then
there is no data on the patient on the
mobile devices yes I'm just curious
these are personal is a variant
the IC is probably got the closest
proximity
very often the best results in I see
okay so so let me let me show you why
how we start so thick okay so i told you
that I'm not a doctor so our medical
advisor which one of the Negro advisors
dr. Howard Newman is ahead of ICU at
Case Western at a time so he makes me
step in ICU for a whole week looking at
that but the troop about why we start in
ICU was I want to tackle the most
difficult the most complex and the most
the data the most active that's how we
do it okay then I see the one I'm sorry
I see you've got the patient right here
in Philly yeah you're not going anywhere
yeah that's actually
yes the the we start at the ICU we
solving the ICU but it's not going to
stop at the SU that's number one number
two I'm going back to the point I'm
making the goal for us is to make the
data in information available you see
the dashboard and application I see you
you know what we can work on dealing
with the emergency the discharge report
we working in hospital to work on the
discharge report to thank the other
piece that i will show you is also we're
working with in a startup company who is
having a personalized video on this
charge before so they they take the
discharge report which we retrieve it
and we decode for them to decoding the
medical order and things that are and
they generating a personalizing
instruction on video and deliver to that
that patient so i'm going back to the
root of so technically is not going to
solving every problem we just start
again calculations is target i see you
but you know what the data is there you
can to nothing down the information that
ability we chief data as information is
there you can present it differently and
you can go to different platforms you
want and the one thing i would say as
someone who's both in ICU doctor and a
clinic doctor and worked in emergency
rooms and does all this stuff what you
realize is you're absolutely correct the
ice using environment where everyone is
together and the patient is there
however the reality is is that about
ninety-five percent of ice you use do
not have physicians in house overnight
so what you also talked about is that
for environment which has 24 hours a day
7 day we care a lot of that care is
still remote by the clinical decision
makers that's point number one point
number two is that any environment both
of the bad patient outcomes that we have
due to cognitive errors and problems
with data processing on the other parts
of the general medical ward are the same
informatics or clinical data retrieval
skills that are needed in the ICU as
well meaning that if you could get the
clinical if you can get complex data
presentation right on the ice you
patient the suggestion is and probably
the reality is is that you'll be able to
get it on the less complex patient
working up the scale is good is where
the problem is is that the reason most
TMR is a failed and ice use or had
problems are not to use is that the
system is optimized for a less complex
data source um what i can tell you and
again if i'm allowed to share 10 and
terry is we've actually used Ric you
test cases that we built an epic and put
some one of them in the zoo etics as
well to look at to see the comparison
between the two systems as well so that
that's the main thing so yes that's used
a closed environment but most ICU care
is done remotely or other least half the
day is you don't put the catheters in
but yeah you get a call and all the
night and so and so is getting worse
something's not looking you want to be
able to look it up you have to be able
to do that now the other thing too i
want to show you an yeah one to follow
point Jeff's comment we didn't talk
about the remote collaboration ribs yes
sorry
let me let me show you one thing then
so let's say I am and by the way this
may not be the the scenario but this is
the capability that we have inside
zoltek so let me creating a case where
this business is at one location and is
and it doesn't have to be I see you or
something like that but the whole idea
is this I am I am at the patient bat and
I want to have consult with somebody
that know more than me okay and I will
place my dashboard in a certain way so
it's no data right now but I place the
dashboard like this okay because my
concern is that time frame with this set
of information so I'm going to go and
say I'm going to send a note to dr.
Barry Jones and ice whatever it is you
can put the note down and the Senate
okay now you probably hear a lot of
things about people talking about the
secure SMS messaging this is the qms
within the boundary of the plow but
switch to the
so dr. Eric Jones will get an
application and this one you see a
consultant with brass tap on it
he will drop at the same location as the
other one there's no miscommunication
but this new trying to tell me is in
front of me and the data is retrieving
from the source of the information but I
am fees and at the same time frame as
same effects like what Vishnu wanna see
11 me TC and i can send the reply after
i change the different context and put
it back i put it very simple is a kind
of web ex for healthcare but it presents
and bring the information at the same
context so that is no miscommunication
you don't have to worry about digging
information because it's all in there in
the dashboard ok now again this is an
example of how you use the necessary
infrastructure and the message system
that we do it it doesn't have to be like
that but that can be really is there
thankfully much
just using that example in terms of a
you know two different scenarios where
you've got an impatient position and
outpatient position then they've got
questions about something assuming that
they have the capabilities log in and
reach out to that attending physician in
terms of why some drug was prescribed
you can see that benefit there in terms
of connecting that you got I can I can
show you also in this ipad here that
assigned to dr. eric jones last night my
engineer has been entering a lot of data
that is out of range and you can see
that it beat me all night okay well
thank you I'm not a physician job but I
can run away but this is the type of
notification that is target to me okay
because oh you probably also notice that
in here there's a knock off and a sign
off a sign off means that and find out
the ship and by the way you're not
allowed to sign off the ship if they [ __ ]
not sign into the ship for that patient
so all the time the concept or zyrtec is
a patient have to have a treaty in the
hospital at least in these cases so so
you're going to be 4i can of course and
say unless Jeff sign in I can't sign up
and then by that way when he signed in
and sign off the next notification and
that patient go to hell that you make no
you can't learn it
he has a passport so it's fishman we can
do that and by the way we know the ipad
ID that you two have so we can wake you
up yes
Jeff
yeah yeah verify we don't the this is
what I learned is you have the Machine
and you it fit the data and only when
the care provider will push and say act
active or authorized and we put it
that
so i have 1 comment to add to what the
unsaid and that is as a physician if I
can't find information in the electronic
health record it's because of one of two
reasons either the information is there
in the EHR and I just can't get to it
all the information is not in the HR at
all and it's in some other places in
some other EHR to me as a clinician I
don't care what the reason is I can't
find it now one of that i can fix myself
if I'm better at using the system then I
become better at finding the information
that's in the electronic health record
or if the electronic health record is
more intuitive and presents the
information to me more efficiently I can
find it but the second problem is an
interoperability problem which is that
if it's in a different EHR there is no
amount of training or no amount of way
there's no way that I can improve myself
in the system enough to find the
information if it simply isn't there so
even though the problem at the surface
looks the same I think the two different
solutions to make sure that that that
information is available to the
physician are very different have very
different approaches and very different
ways to make sure that it happens so
exactly I can test this thing is Terry
doesn't want to call me on days when I
tell him that I'm researching Oh skip
niyama because I'm going to be in really
bad mood the reason is this as an
example just like Vishnu saying why
don't you know the [ __ ] is every data is
their right it just metal turn it off
and then you have to navigate and figure
out which configuration you turn it on
and wish value you turn it up and then
how you going to put that in rap and
view hi just in case of the old script
right in the case of old script
professional it's a different game
different rule different setup
configuration and how you're going to go
and and pull that information out that
data out to turn information
is what we do at the base
and we want to make that thing available
I want to make a bit [ __ ] available
to everybody we want to open not just a
fun and sdk also the backend sdk and use
the data model and by the way as a as a
as a note i'm open to make the data
model better because at the end of the
day I'm not a doctor okay I know how to
set up to their model so that is
universal but you know you guys can help
me
it's in along that line we've already
taken feedback from Jeff and Vishnu and
changed our interface to make it more
intuitive so you know for use by
physicians and caregivers so so as an
example the question like / sample you
know we have the interface on the iphone
but you know what I'm not taking the
same 24 hours on the iphone it's as much
more simpler phone traffic and the
reason I'm designing this one was
basically a net that can change too I'm
saying you at home you have dinner with
your spouse and the eluate come in right
you want to have something that you can
look and say I better run and look for
something I'm just creating scenario or
i can finish dinner okay i want to have
the information in here that's undergo i
can say oh this is serious is not
serious that i can wait for half an hour
later on or an hour so that is also
designed to you know give back the time
to care provider so remember obamacare
can put 48 million more people on health
care and it took 12 years to build a
doctor i don't know how many years
exactly you don't build up too fast
enough okay and in the end it's not
about the baton in hospital it's a spot
to spot the hospital back
and and how you're going to go and and
count that the doctor with that many
thing to remember to deal with that
patient and technically bandwidth
scalability of the system in this case
the scale BTW is not about a hardware
stability of hospital bed is the staff
and how are you going to return that
thing and going back to the blackberry
remember blackberry make everything work
harder without even know about it right
blame them exactly and I'm I I mean is
this mobile device you thought it was
toy guess what they make you work harder
the email you can view the presentation
undergo you can work in the airplane you
name it they train you but that's that's
why we choose should think about I hope
that's not too many doctor in the room
we make the doctor work harder without
their complaint yeah thank you